I want to talk about Sam Harris
let's get a little bit podcast esoteric
we have this clip and there's been a
whole bunch of clips about from Sam
Harris I've been going around familiar
he's a very very big podcaster and um it
appears that he has
I don't know if I don't think he lost
his mind
I think that he embodies the grift
perfectly
you've got people who are passionate and
dedicated to what they believe you've
got people like Brett Weinstein who are
very very adamant about their beliefs
and their expertise and then you get Sam
Harris who just says whatever the most
tepid Centrist neoliberal thing is even
if it makes no sense even if you know he
knows he's lying about what he's saying
so he has this clip I'm gonna play this
clip for you guys you know but dial up
the the deadliness of the pathogen you
know give us something like you know
Airborne Ebola that incubates for a
month you know you don't know you have
it and you're what you walk around
spreading it and it's got you know a 75
fatality rate and it's mostly killing
kids
no one gets to make that choice anymore
I mean then literally the the cops come
in and vaccinate you and
I would say that all of us would agree
to that
the moment again that you turn up The
lethality on the on the pathogen you
turn up the effectiveness of the vaccine
you turn down the risk of the vaccine
give me a truly safe vaccine where
there's not even one documented case of
vaccine injury right so that then you
just have to be completely crazy
to be worried about being vaccinated in
that in that kind of environment
um then it's just a no-brainer then then
we just don't tolerate a diversity of
opinion because the stakes are too high
it's it's a full-on emergency bodies of
kids are being stacked up in Parks right
we there's so many of them we don't know
what to do with them we've got these
mobile morgues and we have a vaccine
that actually works and then we've got
RFK Jr saying you know maybe you don't
want you know you maybe you don't want
to get the jab on Rogan's podcast right
so did you hear what he just said about
RFK Jr he says imagine a scenario where
it's a 75 mortality right the vaccine is
perfect everyone knows it's perfect and
children and children are dying pot on
the street now RFK is saying don't do it
like no no no no no RFK was talking
about now you made up a fake scenario in
your own mind and then criticized the
RFK for saying something in your own
mind dude is losing it he's completely
losing it this was the bodies in the
like he could have children's bodies in
the basement and I would still vote for
him guy right like I I don't really
understand how he made his career happen
when it's based completely apparently in
fiction I wanna I wanna read the sweet
from Dave Smith he said quote imagine if
everything was completely different then
things would be different imagine if
covet had a 100 death rate and the
vaccine was perfectly safe RFK looks
pretty stupid now
it's just absolutely remarkable
I'll tell you what I think Sam Harris is
doing
he just wants to stay on the good side
of the machine
he wants to still maintain some kind of
academic contrarian personality type but
he is worried about being the on the
other side of the machine
that's it
so what he just said made literally
knows I missed the best minute probably
but I I also want to point out too this
whole statement let's just say you have
Airborne Ebola
100 mortality rate or whatever 30 day
incubation like the worst case scenario
and then RFK Jr comes out and says maybe
you don't want to get the vaccine and
the police are going into people's homes
and forcefully vaccinating them my
response right away is I don't trust the
government
Sam Harris's world is so insane it's
like he lives in this reality where the
government is a big marshmallow man that
wants to hug you like bro the the
government quite literally is a demon is
a gigantic demon with fangs trying to
drink your blood okay there there are
some circumstances where that gigantic
demon does things for us because there
are other gigantic demons trying to
drink our blood you see what I'm saying
and so one day the gigantic government
demon
stops a war from happening like stops an
invasion from coming to showing room you
go wow thank you so much demon see this
is why we need the demon then the demon
grabs someone cracks them in half and
drinks their blood and throws their body
like the Sam Harris needs to read a
history book because
governments throughout history in almost
every single circumstance are really
really bad there's good things that come
with government small government I'm
talking like small towns and local stuff
tends to work fairly well but
large-scale stuff tends to be very very
demonic and here is a guide so desperate
to stay in the neoliberal space that he
makes this he he espouses a sophistry
I wish I'd heard it well I think what's
strange is the mental gymnastics he has
to go through to create a scenario where
the world that he wants is correct where
RFK is you know saying the wrong thing
and doing the wrong thing so he creates
a completely fake scenario it it seems
like the worst talking point of all time
I'm sure I say weird stuff to you on the
internet but
it seems indicative of the culture he is
in where I could give you a completely
hypothetical situation that I have made
up and then apply it to a real world
example that actually has nothing to do
with it I love this response from
Tristan Tate he said if ifs and butts
were candies and nuts
that's an excellent excellent response
to Sam Harris I think what happened is
and the reason why I I want to talk
about this is like this is the
intellectual dark web guy
this big podcast what was this podcast
called
yeah you remember what it's called it
was Sam Harris something intelligent
something right I don't know and it was
him and he would sit around with Joe
Rogan and Ben Shapiro and Jordan
Peterson and Dave Rubin and they would
talk about all this stuff I was like oh
very fascinating and now he's been going
out saying making sense that was making
sense criticizing Joe Rogan saying he's
captured by his audience I'm like bro
that's quite literally you Joe Joe Rogan
drink just drink Bud Light Joe Rogan on
two occasions cracked up in a Bud lines
of the whole thing was silly despite the
massive backlash against the company
it's not audience capture that's Joe
Rogan just being him and doing what he
wants to do this guy is willing to say
whatever nonsense he can just try and
stay in the Limelight not piss off the
neoliberal establishment
that's the definition of grifting I
suppose
well I'd like to get him in studio at
some point it seems like we have a lot
of uh Familiar of similar friends he was
just with uh with um on Modern wisdom
right yeah but he won't do it he's like
he said in one interview I'd love to
talk with Jordan or or Brett you know
about these things and then he literally
doesn't talk to them
or I don't think you mentioned Brad it
was like Jordan and Joe or something I
don't know Brett Weinstein yeah yeah and
then Brett's like he literally won't
talk to us about this and Brett's an
evolutionary biologist
so it's just like he's he's it's Plastic
Man yeah he knows he's supposed to say
oh no of course I'd be willing to talk
to them and it's like then do it
immediately the entire he knows his
argument's flawed he wouldn't win an
argument so that's why he won't if he's
allowed to make his own facts and
everyone agreed with him 100 then he
could win so I don't understand he can
just make up scenarios all day long and
he'll be fine right that's what we
learned from this interview yeah
I think that's so weird to make this
hypothetical because you don't like RFK
Jr so much that you would say if the
virus was more deadly and also vaccines
were better and also there was a massive
emergency like none of those things
happened point two one time that has
happened where this has been the case he
can't even cite a historical like
precedent it doesn't make any sense to
me it was either playing The Devil's
Advocate to the point where he's playing
dumb I think become the devil so I think
what happened with him is he has Trump
derangement syndrome that is so weird
coming from a guy that's supposed to be
like an intellectual I don't know
here's what I think happens
he sees Trump losing and he thinks to
himself oh man
if I'm on the side of trump
I'm on the wrong side of History I'm
done
I'm gonna come out and say whatever to
say whatever I have to say to be this
Centrist but still in the good side of
the machine personality I get that
forces him to adopt a bunch of positions
that make no sense I get that from Neil
deGrasse Tyson too he just said there
was many genders yeah he's a scientist
and he said that yep uh and I'm like I
want to be diplomatic with these guys
but it's just to the point where like
you know if you're gonna be dumb you're
not part of the song You're gonna be
dumb they're evil
either one or the other either you're
they're plaintively stupid or they're
acting maliciously so this is a scary
reality when you see someone like Neil
deGrasse Tyson come out and be like
there are more than two genders you're
like okay how much did they pay you
because like come on dude you can look
up any fifth grade science book and
it'll tell you about the the I'm sorry
more than two Sexes that you look up any
any fifth grade biology book there are
two Sexes oh so did he say there's more
than two genders but no Sexes he said
that we've learned now and then you've
got that guy uh um Colin Wright posted
this the guy who said that there are six
biological sexes it's like these people
are unwell two plus two equals five
their their world view is shattered I
don't see how they can build a cohesive
Community if their worldview makes no
sense well
you know what I'm thinking about is
religion how do you build a cohesive uh
Community around something that cannot
be proved like if you tell a kid two
plus two equals five but but look here's
two and here's two if you count them
that's one two three four but two plus
two equals five the kid will think okay
I can accept these things even though I
don't I can't prove why or it doesn't
make sense but I will accept that those
are both true and so you could make it
now they're
logical Pathways they're reasoning
breaks because now they can't connect
dots is it do you think that I don't I
don't want to get too deep into religion
but people that just blindly accept have
faith in things that are unprovable that
they're they have like broken logic
Pathways no
do you have to break your logic Pathway
to believe something without proof no
what do you mean well without without
evidential proof so why would you ever
believe it so let's say you stumble
across a Chuck a spattering of chocolate
on your floor and there is a cake on
your counter that is destroyed something
ate your cake and got the chocolate on
the floor
the first thing we do is we make an
assumption we form a hypothesis okay I'm
going to go ahead and assume that
someone smashed and destroyed the cake
that's apparent by the fact the cake is
smashed and destroyed I'm now going to
assume that it was not a human who did
it because a human would not flip the
cake and the chocolate onto the ground
oh hold on why would you believe
something without proof why would you
operate under this this uh concept
without actually having been able to
prove it the only way to lead yourself
to prove it is if you operate under the
assumption it is potentially true so now
you're sitting here saying it's going to
take me a while to figure out what
happened to this cake but I think it was
an animal that did it okay now we assess
how many animals we have now we have a
cat we have a dog likely not going to be
the cat maybe the cat though the cat may
be like Boop booped it off the counter
maybe the dog jumped up and got it we're
going to choose a hypothesis and then
we're going to pursue it we're going to
operate under an assumption so that we
can try and figure out the truth
now it makes trying to be both the cat
and the dog are covered in chocolate and
you're going to have to operate without
being able to know for sure
my point here is that's logic if you can
look at a cake on the ground and slipped
over and be like okay none of the humans
here did this right it's possible they
did but unlikely they did so I'm not
going to pursue that course of
Investigation that's using logic now if
a child can't understand the concepts
because they've been told two plus two
equals five they look at the cake on the
ground they look at the cake on the
counter they see the smash that smash
the chuck on the floor and they go
a rabbit broke into my house and got my
cake wow they'll be more likely to
believe nonsensical insane things that
you should not be led to believe thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time